anh ạ
anh alo
alo chào các bạn ạ
ờ ờ
I my phone cho ạ Ừ không sớm không muộn
em ạ
à à
từ hôm nay mình sẽ học về really thư
viện YouTube và sẽ biết dùng Cài hàm
răng của nó
trước khi đấy bây giờ thật sự cái đã nhỉ
Xin chào Phương Linh phẩm trước nhà nghỉ
học ngon ạ
it is
à à
em
rảnh tâm sự đặt Gmail Hà Nội các bạn
không ad
anh alo
Em thích bé à
anh
alo alo
rồi Không hiểu sao thỉnh thoảng dây hình
như có vấn đề rồi cái nồi cái mic của
mình nói thật đi đợt to hơn Ngon
xem thêm một cái làm cái đoạn mà à
Cô gái đã là video ngắn trước đã nhé ạ
Ý
tao hỏi
vụ tai nạn thôi
à à
ừ ừ
em đã hỏi discussion is personal selling
and add all This is you are ottoman
carreras gi và Yoona Men colognes à
ở tầng 9 đây ngoại hình như là cậu ấy
thể gộp thành 1 cầu dài được đón chị đại
khái nó là hoặc phải đại khai ý nữa này
Nói thẳng luôn là bạn không phải nhân
vật chính trong câu chuyện người khác
bạn là nên vật chính trong cuộc đời bạn
ông ạ
Cái này tương tự gần như mình từng nói
đó là
ờ các bạn nên cái tự tin sống cho chính
mình thôi đừng để người khác nghĩ gì
nhiều
không Đừng cũng như mà không phải sống
ích kỷ Nói chung vào cái kế cân bằng đấy
khi là khó anh Bởi vì a nhiều người thì
biến thành bảo thủ Quá chẳng quan tâm
người khác nó cái gì cả xã hội tẩy chay
họ cá sấu hội lên lại lên án phản ánh họ
khi họ cũng kệ thì thế không đúng
thế
hả gửi OTP
em gửi OTP được ra nó không khác gì làm
cái vụ gửi email nhưng mỗi tội nó còn
tốn tiền gửi
mất phí mà gửi mã gửi tin nhắn đến mất
phí ngoài lại khác gì làm đâu em chọn
theo dụng thư viện thôi
Anh ở cài đặt cài đặt tí được
Hi
hi cái vừa rồi trong video nói luôn là
tuổi hai mươi thằng ai dính trường hợp
đấy các bạn ở đây chắc tầm tầm tuổi đấy
thôi hai mấy có thể là
bây giờ là học cấp 3 có thể thế hoặc đại
học Mình hướng đến đối tượng chẳng hạn
thì tầm tầm đấy
cha ở cùng cố mạng sẽ có 1 vai mình xem
có xem thống kê đó là gạo cũng có vài
tấm ảnh trên 52 một phần trăm gì đó tập
30 độ lên nhưng mà đấy không biết là các
bạn có giả mạo tuổi không ạ
anh
nghe thử cái là có rất nhiều bạn đang
chênh vênh
anh ở đây phải chính với Huệ hơn nửa mới
tìm đến cái kết của tôi
như vậy xem cho vui nữa à
bộ
phim mình nghĩ à
các bạn kinh doanh như thế thì luôn dậm
chân tại chỗ không dám đi đâu cả Làm gì
cũng sợ say vân vân thì mình mình nên tự
tin hơn và cậu
khi
mọi thứ đều do mình quyết định nóng bạn
nếu mà kể cả sai thì thôi làm lại Nhã
Nhã đi Đứng dậy Đúng không ạ từ trẻ nên
thế
à à
anh
vẫn chọn chỉ biết khuyên thế Kể cái việc
có cái video nữa không chữa tôi xem tuổi
chưa lưu đó chỉ là kiểu chúng ta không
không nên suy nghĩ về bản lùi tính Tôi
là một người khác khó chịu việc là ai đó
bi quan quá Tí chị ạ Chưa làm nó sợ nó
có vấn đề gì đó
minh tính trường hợp thì đúng mình tính
trường hợp lập trình viên mình phải tính
rất nhiều trường hợp nhưng không đề nghĩ
cách là quan nhất cả không ở Mỹ vừa cốt
mình không ngờ có bất cả Có mờ nghĩ việc
là người dùng sẽ luôn nhập đúng người
dùng sẽ luôn thao tác đúng không chuyện
đấy mình với tất cả trường hợp mà trường
hợp mà người dùng nhập sai nhiều hơn
người người dùng nhập Đúng
rất nhiều nên là thực ra lập trình nhiên
là con người thấy bi quan ấy bởi vì lúc
nào bắt rất nhiều trường hợp sai mà
không nghĩ trường hợp lý tưởng nhất là
người dùng nhập đúng hết
Ừ
nhưng nhưng mà
anh nói thế không phải là vì có quá
nhiều trường hợp thì lập trình viên bỏ
không làm nữa
chúng ta nhìn nhìn theo nhiều khía cạnh
nhưng mà
Luôn hướng đến cái mục đích Cô ấy là mục
đích đúng hết Nó ngoại
thì thì làm mình mình nghĩ à Nói chung
cái thời mà mình trước khi học lập trình
viên và sau khi học có một cách tử tế
nhưng cái thực tế 52 mình mình bảo học
Như đùa ấy của gì à mình thực sự mình
vẫn chưa đam mê Cái này lắm cho đến kiểu
khi làm đến đồ ăn hay và khi mà xăng tự
làm một cái sản phẩm cho riêng mình sau
đó đi thực tập mình với lò mụn hình dung
hơn về cái ngành này và mình mới thực sự
là kiểu
họ như nhà mới bắt đầu động não phải
dùng từ bắt đầu độc não vì toàn bộ những
thì kiến thức mà thầy thầy dạy trên lớp
từ các là mình cũng chỉ copy code
em sửa lại theo ý của mình mình cũng
nghĩ à Mình chưa nghĩ sâu về Toán thầy
bảo gì thì mình chỉ cậu nghĩa là thì
phải thêm đoạn này theo dõi này tự mò
cũng có tự mò nhưng mà chỉ thêm một vài
cái nữa không nghĩ sâu rồi phải to lắm
Anh không nghĩ các tất cả trường hợp
Ừ nhưng mà khi mà về sau này thì mình
cảm thấy là à
ở Pháp Luật trình chiếu cho mình suy
nghĩ mọi cái thứ thấu đáo hơn một tí nó
có lôgích hơn một tí nữa
lễ hội bé ở hồi cấp 3 tôi được học sinh
trung bình còn suýt học sinh yếu mèo ông
ạ
hồi hồi cấp 2 tôi học sinh giỏi đi thi
thành phố có thừa thứ điểm mạnh 10 cho
vault
nơi cấp 3 có bị mày chơi bị kiểu bị làm
vân vân nhiều cái tôi cứ nghĩ hồi cấp 3
đấy tôi tôi nhiều lúc tôi còn nghĩ rằng
là tôi ngu hơn Sao hồi cấp 2 không thông
minh bằng gặp lại cực hợp cấp hay quá
khứ của mình có khi nó chửi mình ngu Vì
mình thấy cái gì mình cũng tệ không Thứ
Nếu mà khi mà học sau đó thì tôi nghĩ là
thôi xong có khi mình dành hết trí thông
minh mình dài hết cho hồi cấp 1 có hai ở
với học trò học Châu Á ấy đấy Tại sao
lên cấp 3 mình kém thế
hồ sơ khi lên đại học khi học cái ngành
này xong tôi bây giờ mới thấy à bây giờ
rồi mình khẳng định tới thông minh hơn
rồi hơi trước tôi không tự ti việc là
mình nó ngu dần đi nữa
Ở đây có tôi có tự tin ở mình Đang ngu
dàn đấy thẻ vội việc hồi có một à công
một Tôi là kiểu màu sách mà hồi cấp 2
thì tôi cũng đi thi có thứ
hồi cấp 2 điểm phẩy của tôi môn Vật Lý
là nó ạ là 9,9 ý
à Xong rồi lên lại lên cấp 3 kiểm tra
miệng không phải trưởng nhưng mà sẽ ra
cái vụ lần này không có cay là để không
thì do là chẳng hiểu sao bị nhớ Nhầm cái
định luật 2 Newton 3 Newton nhầm mỗi thế
thôi hãy cho không luôn lại cái vậy Rõ
ràng là kiểu vẫn nhớ vẫn nhớ tất cả định
nó chẳng qua bị nhầm 2,3 đấy cho không ạ
anh nói tâm sự tình thế thôi
mình mình
Ừ mình vẫn chỉ muốn thỉnh thoảng động
viên các bạn và giống như thầy giáo của
mình hơi trước thì à
cô giáo mình ngồi trước dậy thứ nhất là
tâm sự nhiều hơn dậy này Thứ hai là
thì ngày nào luôn nói luôn nói việc là
các bạn phải đi làm các bạn phải đi tập
vào phải làm đồ án các thứ thứ ngày nào
cũng
mà
ngày nào cũng nhắc đi nhắc lại những cái
điều đấy để cho cậu hẳn vào trong tâm
trí các bạn thì việc đấy các bạn sẽ
không sợ không sợ cái đấy nữa bạn sẽ
kiểu
cũng nghĩ dần về việc đấy
Ừ đấy là bài toán về tâm lý học ngày nào
cũng nhớ
Xin chào khi nào tổn sẽ thế Ngày nào tự
nhắc mấy ông đi thực tập rồi cùng khi
ông về sau đi thực tập thật chứ không
phải học xong kiểu như này thì ông mà
thôi để đấy phải phải bắt tay vào thì nó
mới kiểu ra ngô ra khoai được đúng ạ ạ
từ
hôm mình có xem mã 22 buổi video hôm
trước thì được là những câu hỏi mà có
hỏi trong đấy được khá ít và mình có trả
lời ngay trong buổi mấy rồi có một cái
câu này thì là có một bạn hôm trước nói
mình
và mình thấy da Thực ra cũng nhiều bạn
như thế này và chính mình từng thế nên
mình sẽ trả lời câu này
Ờ
Cái này là bạn Sai lầm đầu tiên từ chính
mình hồi trước
và bây giờ khá nhiều bạn cũng cũng bị
thế đó là
thơ ca thì mình
cho nên cầu toàn ở một mức tương đối
ờ ờ
mà tại sao lại dùng từ cầu toàn đây bởi
vì Giả sử bây giờ mình bảo các bạn làm
cái đón một này là trong cách bán hàng
thế này thì các bạn sẽ nghĩ là kiểu mình
sẽ thứ nhất ở dốc hết sức vào nó để nó
hoàn thiện nó kéo chỉ tiêu Dư đầu không
cuối từ giao diện cho đến và date cơ thử
kiểm tra chặt chẽ đã tao bay đón Vân Nói
chung là tất cả đều phải hoàn hảo kiểu
đấy đó nếu mà Thứ nhất là không khái
niệm hoàn hảo thứ hai đó là
anh đón một này nó vẫn không áp dụng
nhiều công nghệ là một không ai dụng mô
hình là hai thành ra là
càng sửa các bạn Thể càng dài dòng và
càng khó sửa
càng xinh ra nhiều vấn đề các bạn muốn
thêm tính năng nó lại thêm vấn đề Cảm ơn
nhiều cái thậm chí là sửa ra đây rất khó
là tối ưu
ạ Và nếu mà các bạn chỉ chăm chăm làm cả
như thế
thì khi mà đi phỏng vấn cả ạ
Các bạn chỉ khoe được có một sản phẩm
bộ 3 sản phẩm đấy các bạn đã tốn quá
nhiều ra để sửa nữa các bạn biết được
người ta vẫn thường hay nói mình từng
nói rồi nó 80 80 20 Đó là các bạn mất
hai mươi phần trăm thời gian để cốt 80
phần trăm gian còn lại để mà sửa cốt
test sữa thế là các bạn tốn quá nhiều
thời gian để sửa cái như thế các bạn sẽ
không làm được cái thứ khác không học
thêm rồi cái gì mới
nên là thay vì các bạn chỉ tập trung làm
một cái đồ án
Ừ thì các bạn nên
dựa vào những cái sai sót của đoán một
để mà khi mà xanh khi một kết thúc đoán
một này khi mình cho bảo các bạn bảo vệ
xong đó một đấy các bạn đừng có
động lại nó nữa mà bất ngờ nhảy sang đồ
ăn hay nó sẽ theo mô hình
Ê bà áp dụng công nghệ mới bị sẽ rút ra
được nhiều bài học từ nó
thì mình không nên quên nó đi nhưng mình
cũng không nên cái động lại nó làm gì
nữa
và mình sẽ Và thậm chí là không những đồ
ăn 2 mà các bạn vẫn thể tự làm cái sản
phẩm riêng cho mình một cái gọi là Pep
Vô trách nói rồi để mà theo cá nhân sở
thích của mình để cho mình đam mê hơn
với những ngày này và các bạn cũng làm
nó ở một mức tương đối thôi Giống như
mình từng chia sẻ rất nhiều tool
Facebook đấy có rất nhiều tool mà hoàn
toàn thể làm tối ưu được hơn nhưng mà
nếu mà cư chỉ chăm chăm ngày nào đi sửa
đi sửa lại một vài cái tôn chơi trò này
cốt của mình nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ ra ít và
mình sẽ không họ không học hỏi được
nhiều hơn
cho mình mình sẽ phải quen dần việc là
tạm bỏ nó đi để mình nhảy sang cái thư
khác đúng ạ ạ
ừ ừ
à à
Em tự học trang web node.js pp học vệ có
độ làm fulspec cuốn sách ở đây Bây giờ
đôi khi là nó sau đây thì có thể biết rõ
Swift nhưng mà Thậm chí anh em biết thì
xét thì cả
nhưng mà CF bây giờ chỉ cần bút tre hồi
chặng đua hồi
nên làm sản phẩm gì để mang đi phỏng vấn
á thì em cứ làm một cái trang web bình
thường thôi và nên nên là trang web nó
có giải quyết một cái bài toán ở đó và
nó kiểu dạng liên quan đến việc là giống
như trong web bán hàng kiểu như này thì
đó là bài toán về
Thương Mại Đầu Tư Và và nó là kiểu dạng
và nó có hai loại đối tượng là chủ yếu
nó là khách hàng với quản lý các bạn nên
làm quen với việc là chia làm như thế
sau đó thì Hương đến mai toán nghiệp vụ
hơn cũng được nhiệm vụ là gì thì tức tức
là sự kiện nó sẽ tiện lợi hơn cho người
dùng nó chuyên sâu hơn nó không chỉ mỗi
xem thêm sửa xóa nữa phải tối ưu cho
người dùng dùng dùng tiện này Thống kê
rõ này thêm sản phẩm dễ này Đấy chưa thế
Ừ Ok nói cho mà Bộ hôm nay bây giờ mình
sẽ bắt đầu dạy về Yuri Đông ạ
ở
đầu tiên thì Yuri là gì đã ngoại giao
lên Mẹ nói nó không phải một phen word
Hồi trước mình cứ nhầm Nó là hạt ngôn
ngữ riêng cơ Thực ra gian nói chuyện một
thư viện thư viện
ra Switch và nó khá là to
nó khá là nặng nên là thời gian bây giờ
rất nhiều trang web thì không Không chèn
thêm cái này vào nữa ngồi trước thì có
nhưng bây giờ là loại bỏ gần như là dậy
ý Trang web nào trang web cũng rồi còn
những cái thằng một lớn thằng mới thì
thấy à Cái này bởi vì thư viện như mình
vừa dùng vừa nói nó xa to to lắm chị ạ
nó chứa rất nhiều cái hàm
nó đây sẽ cho bé uống xem sẽ nó bao
nhiêu nòng cốt nhé
ở đây chấm Mi làm chứa nó kia chấm mi nó
lén lại rồi
à mà nó còn gì này đã bỏ chấm mini
không thấy là nó sẽ rất là dày nhé Rất
nhiều dòng cốt rất nhiều cái mà mình
không áp dụng không Nó dụng này ra là nó
sẽ rất nặng
anh lên thai BS trang web chèn thêm về
thư viện lại vào hiện tại sao mình
Nguyễn dạy vì thực ra là
những trang web mới được này Không chèn
thêm cái này
anh nói nếu bảo nó dùng về phương Quốc
gia Switch còn nếu mà không dùng dạy phê
Quốc gia Switch thì đôi khi vẫn sẽ chả
được cái này là gần nhất thừa là anh là
mày học cái này cốt là để cho các bạn
biết qua với việc viết ra Speed và nhanh
hơn tiện hơn và cũng biết qua về setup
rồi các thứ thứ sợi tơ là lựa chọn đối
tượng hãy chọn thẻ gì đó Được mà từ đây
mình sẽ dạy các bạn về cả giấc xr nữa
thì cái này là khá nhanh và tiện
hình ảnh cây thư viện này vẫn chỉ để tro
cốt ra Speed nhanh hơn Chứ thứ nhất nó
vẫn là ra Spear thứ hai là
thì các bạn hoàn toàn thể biết cái này
rồi Các bạn à
anh về sau làm ra ship thuần này hay à
xanh Nhảy xong Facebook thì bảo nó sẽ
hiểu thôi
nghe mình nghĩa vẫn dậy được cái này
ừ ừ
Ừ ok đầu tiên thì để để học nói đến nhà
mình phải chè nó mà mình sẽ có đoạn này
bạn này sẽ ra sweep xuộc lại sau đó đi
cái thư viện này mình không nhớ Bây giờ
GV khuyến mãi nhiều nhưng thực ra 3.5 là
quá quá đủ rồi
Chưa bao giờ mình sẽ áp dụng nó ở đâu
trọng thế Thì đây mình sẽ bắt đầu chuyển
lại sạc Quay lại cái trang web cơ bản
này các bạn hình dung bây giờ Giả sử nhé
Bây giờ Bây giờ tôi làm bất cứ cái gì là
sự bấm vào xem thì tiếc thì thì không
nói nó nhảy sang hẳn trang khác để xem
thông tin thì rõ ràng nhưng mà bây giờ
mình ấn thêm vào giỏ hàng thì bạn thế là
thứ nhất là người dùng không cần nhìn
cái giao diện thêm vào giỏ hàng nóng rõ
diện thêm vào giỏ hàng với đấy tôi cần
in ra cái giỏ hàng như thế này Thế là
không nhất là khi bấm vào đây là bản
chất là nó là phải xử lý thôi mà không
có giao diện gì cả rồi nó cần phải
chuyển hướng lại quay lại bên trang trụ
này ngay đúng ạ Chứ không phải là cho
người dùng nhìn thấy đoạn reason vừa rồi
ờ
ờ có bác mình sẽ nói qua rồi các phương
trình thôi à
Ừ mình không gà bị không nắm rõ ra sự
Swift một cách từng tặng lắm Để mà giải
thích các bạn rất nhiều khái niệm
em chắc là về sau mình sẽ đề cập nó hoạt
động như thế nào Xem các bạn có dễ hình
dung không nhé
anh nói chung là đại khái bây giờ mình
bấm vào Thêm giỏ hàng thì các bạn cứ
hiểu là bấm vào đưa nhà thêm được vào
giỏ hàng nhưng mà không cần tải lại
trang thì mình sẽ làm như thế nào
Ừ đấy thì thì bây giờ mình sẽ có khái
niệm Nhưng mà trước khi liền cái khái
niệm này
thì
mình sẽ làm khái niệm đơn giản nhất để
cho bạn dễ hình dung về cái
really thể làm được những gì đã trước
khi nhảy sang Iraq ngoại về mình có file
test này để mình sẽ có file that chấm TP
này à
à à
ạ
Bây giờ mình sẽ có là
ờ ờ
em thật sự là điềm gì đó đi ạ
lên như này ờ nên thừa mình đã đi Nó
không phải theo lên nhé ạ tùy
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
anh nghe sự thật tên ID tên đi
mình sẽ chèn thêm tới đoạn II
ở đây là chuyện thêm cái thư viện Gia
Huy giờ mình sẽ Script này thì đầu tiên
học về cái J có lý thì thứ là ngay từ
hồi mà mình dạy ra Suite thì mình hẹn
tôi nói các bạn đó Rocket nó sẽ được
chạy khi mà chan được tải xong đó ngoạn
và ghi lại càng khẳng định thêm đấy một
lần nữa và khi mà tài liệu được tải xong
lẽ sẽ Khái niệm và đo comment chậm rãi
đi ra đi là nó sẵn sàng rồi này khi tài
liệu được hoặc tải xong hết rồi mới bắt
đầu với bắt đầu chạy cái ra sweep
tức là xa nhà em chỉ khi mà Giả sử có ý
phút này nó được Lord nó được phải hiển
thị ra xong rồi thì mình gắn chức năng
cho cái nút hoa cả mình lấy dữ liệu từ
bút và vận thì mới được còn nếu mà giọt
sự cái hàng này còn chưa được tải xong
thì gọi đến nó nữa sẽ thì nó sẽ báo là
cái cái phút này không tồn tại ở sẽ
không chạy được cái nên là mình anh cái
điệp khúc này nó đó không cần ra đi này
thì thứ nhất là mình đang dạy các bạn
bằng sắp xitec nên là mình sẽ khuyên các
bạn cài cái Pocket là gj để nó có gợi ý
khá đầy đủ
a a a
A và khi mà cài này xong mình tắt đi mà
giá này mình gọi chữ đây đi này Đấy nó
xảy ra nó sẽ một là các bạn dùng di đo
comment Lady là nhau mình sẽ dùng đôla
lại tiền mà mình hoàn toàn Dũng đôla ở
trong những cái sau nữa
à à
ở đó thời tiếp theo là đây sẽ có những
khái niệm là nó sẽ gọi selector giống
hết ra CS của mình đã từng dậy đó là có
thể gọi nó bằng tên thẻ gọi bằng ai đi
Gọi bằng nhiều cái nữa bây giờ sử trong
trường hợp này mình gọi bằng ai đi sẽ là
đô la này
Ê
thằng thằng mái đi không ạ tên này sau
đó thì mình hoàn toàn thế cho nó ra sự
cho nó 1 cái giá trị trước cả này
thì sẽ là như thế này Long nghe chẳng ạ
chấm va này nó sẽ giống ra Speed Hồi
trước mình học Trần Văn Lưu ý đó là gán
giá trị cho thằng này nếu lại các bạn
khi kiểu này dàn áo chị cho cấy nào có
ai đi là tên mình sẽ thử nhé
ở đó bạn thấy ra nó sẽ thứ nhất là ra
Speed về các bạn nó sang anh gần như
giống như lúc đầu đã được điện sẵn ở
trong hát Từ lâu vậy nhưng mà không Đây
chẳng qua di chạy ra sức chạy nhanh nên
nó nó cập nhật ở đây luôn
em đứng yên là các bạn thấy à Thế khi
thở ra chả có tác dụng gì à Mình cần lấy
cái gì mình nhập trong đây rồi khi chị
ra cái ở dưới này thì sao đối ngoại Thì
bây giờ mình sẽ mình sẽ khái niệm này
tên này mà mình hòa Toán thì có những
cái sự kiện của nó thường mình có thể
dùng sự sự kiện ở trên như thế này trên
này tức là sao và khi mà thay đổi cái
khi mà thay đổi xong cái này
thì thì sẽ cập nhật là sự mình sẽ có đây
một cái
một cái đít một cái ID là kết quả
Anh và mỗi khi cái này cập nhật thì mình
sẽ có
chậm kết quà Các bạn nhớ vụ inner HTML
sẽ in ra đúng không ạ in ra cái đấy in
ra HTML mơ trong trường hợp này mình một
là mình sẽ in ra
chứ không phải HTML mà mình có thể
innotek nghĩa là chữ rồi không phải HTML
hoặc gọi email hàng HTML tùy sẽ có khói
khái niệm ở đây
hôm trước mình cũng có xem cái vụ mà
liên quan khá nguy hiểm khi mà mình in
hẳn ra HTML thì dễ bị dính
hết khủng thứ nghe các bạn hãy im lặng
Tách ngay cũng được cho chắc là sự đây
là
các bạn đã Điền
xe tải này sau đó thì nói đến cái gì đó
cứ tạm cho bạn nha
Cái khi vào sự kiện che này xảy ra khi
mà bạn click ra ngoài hoặc em tô gì gió
thì nó mới thì nó mới cậu chạy cái tre
này như thế
ạ bây giờ để mà mình lấy cái thông tin
này để truyền vào trong cái sau cái bạn
đã Điền này thì mình sẽ có khái niệm là
một là có như thế này Có 2 cách để mà
làm một là các bạn thể khai báo biến là
điền tên bằng
tên chấm và giống như hồi trước mà mình
làm là khai báo biến lấy cái giá trị từ
cái input xong rồi đổ nó vào như thế này
nhỏ như này nhưng mà mình thường là khi
mà làm gj và bìa làm trong hàm như thế
này thì người ta không tác dụng cái này
nữa Tại sao bởi vì à
thì các bạn thấy là cái tên là lặp lại
hai lần này và khi vào trong cái phông
chữ như thế này nha mình sẽ có khái niệm
đô la ĐT cái rít của Hoàng Gia Swift rất
rất là khó hiểu thì mình sẽ cho các bạn
xem video này cho sẽ hiện đau não như
thế nào nhưng đến cuối buổi nhé Còn bây
giờ thì các bạn chỉ cần hiểu cái thằng
giết ở trong trường hợp phong sinh này
nó sẽ ra gọi đến thằng gọi đến thằng này
thôi trong trường hợp này nếu mà mình
gọi dualit thì sẽ ra gọi đến hành chính
là này Đấy thì mình sẽ là đô la just như
thế này thì các bạn thấy thì ra kết quả
vẫn thế thôi
chứ quả vẫn thế nhưng thì các bạn sẽ
hiểu rít trong trường hợp này nó là cái
thằng cha
Ừ nó Gọi nó Gọi đến phương trình này
hỗ trợ
à còn tại còn các bạn hỏi mình tại sao
viết bằng chữ như thế nào thứ như này
các thứ thứ gì Cái này là
A Gọi khái niệm có Bác vừa lại bạn kia
bảo ấy thì ra khái niệm này nó cấu trúc
của nó là như thế đoạn chuyển chỉ cần
viết đúng như này nó sẽ hiểu sẽ nhận
mình không dùng cả cái even này luôn
không không không dùng để ai luôn
thằng này hoàn toàn là nó sẽ gọi đến một
cái hàm và mình và mình sẽ Vĩnh ghi cốt
vào trong cái Hàn này để nó chạy cũng
mỗi lần khi mà có sự kiện là thay đổi
khiến phút thì nó sẽ chạy toàn bộ cốt ở
trong này được chưa ạ nhưng mà hoàn toàn
của các bạn thấy có khái niệm là khi áp
và khí đao khi up tất cả khi mà mình bấm
bấm phím xuống rồi mình Nhấc tay lên
hoặc khi đa là khi mình bấm phím xuống
sộ thôi nó đã cập nhật nó sẽ như này
trong nó sẽ trải nghiệm các bạn thấy nó
giống như kiểu tức thời nó rất là nhanh
đúng không ạ Đấy
ở đây là khái niệm về thời ra cái này
toàn bộ làm bằng da ship được nhưng mà
nó sẽ dài dòng hơn rồi làm bằng JJ các
bạn thì nó khá nhanh
à à
Anh vừa trả lời cái cầu bạn Duy và hỏi
đó ngoại đấy
ờ ờ đấy thì vừa rồi Mình đã biết qua
việc là mình có thể thao tác với in phút
các thứ thứ Ngoài ra còn nhiều còn nhưng
thao tác được cả với cả cái đít gì đó
khác nữa mình sẽ có khái niệm sợi tơ
ngay cho nó đi truyền dữ liệu vào được
không ạ
à Còn bây giờ thì bây giờ mình sẽ thử áp
dụng để mà làm những cái thứ là trang
web của mình thì thực ra là
cho tao xem lại trang web mình nhé Xem
trang web của mình có thể dùng được
những cái gì
có thể là bên đăng ký ạ biến đăng ký các
bạn thể vides kiểm tra vahs từ thứ nhờ
vai đấy thì tôi chưa định dạy Bộ hôm nay
đồng nghĩa để ở
ở buổi sao zậy
Ừ tôi sẽ dậy mấy ông chắc trước về cho
mấy ông thầy thích thú vị và mấy ông sẽ
hứng thú và để mà
buổi bởi yên tâm là tôi sẽ dạy các bạn
toàn bộ I really những cái mà tôi sẽ dạy
các bạn này ờ
sự thay đổi số lượng chữa đặt hàng này
họ thay đổi số lượng này sau đó thì chị
mua đồ xong rồi và hết sao bìa rồi thống
kê còn gì còn gì nữa thì các bạn với nhé
mình nhá á môi còn cả bình luận cộng mà
đánh giá nữa chẳng ra sao cả bạn đấy
anh nói chung và con thế con
à Còn thể thêm một vài cái nữa
vì vậy ông có nhắc tôi dần nha
à à mà suốt à cũng được
Ừ mai
search2 xuất tất cả tìm kiếm kiểu có cái
tìm kiếm Đài hoặc cứ gõ này đâu Nó sẽ
hiển thị một là lại lại ở chơi thằng này
sửa gõ ở đây ạ Tôi thường gõ thấy không
biết hay có không
Ừ đấy thì nó đã gợi ý ra ở đây như này
cái này tức là nó sẽ dùng ra Swift nó
tìm kiếm chữ Dell ở trên
đi tìm kiếm tất cả sản phẩm đều ở trên
sever Xong rồi trả về gợi ý đây cho các
bạn như này gọi lại search đấy chị ạ
anh chat chat là cái khó rất nhiều nha
tôi sẽ không dậy cái ông về chắc khát là
nó sẽ phải nó sẽ khác hoàn toàn
brightest này xảy ra là nó dễ hơn nhiều
chị tìm kiếm trong một cái bảng là không
lớn lắm cần trát Chắc nó rất nặng và rất
lớn làm thời gian thực làm chi cả kết
nối người này với người kia còn còn treo
thời gian thực nữa là khó hơn có cái này
thì vẫn giả đã kết nối một chiều với đa
tao bay thôi một chiều dẫn làm chè ông
không truyền lên không Chỉ cần lấy thông
tin về đâu ạ thì nó sẽ dễ hơn
ở bảng xếp hạng bảng xếp hạng thì lại
không thấy qua liên quân trồng cây rồi
em ạ
em trả lời bình luận
Ừ ừ thì làm bình luận mà còn làm trả lời
bình luận thì cứ ca thì nó lại là không
liên quan đến bên dưới lắm Nó chỉ là là
xử lý pp thôi
Ô thế cái đấy là xử lý nó là chức năng
của bên TP mà thực ra là
mình lại không nghĩ định dậy cái đấy của
Vì ạ bởi vì A mình đang hướng các bạn
làm trong web bán hàng thưa các bạn cứ
nhảy sang một cái tính năng nó nó là
tính năng kiểu đứng yên à Có thì tốt
nhưng mà nó không phải tính năng kiểu
quan trọng lắm ở trong cái trang web bán
hàng hoặc không có bình luận gì chứ cả
nó cũng chẳng sao cả à
Ừ đúng rồi nó là khái niệm cũng có thể
gọi là ô tô complete ngựa ô tô complete
là chuyển nghĩa trị hỗ trợ cái cái tên
đó nói lên tất cả Đó là tự động điền tự
động Điền Điền điểm tên thôi nhưng đây
là nó thể gợi ý ra vừa rồi Các bạn thấy
cầm di ảnh hai ra gì do nữa kém gì là nó
đã đề xuất một cách khánh chi tiết hơn
không phải một autocomplete
Ừ thì ế sẽ gọi là tình yêu kiểu Lyon
rice tức là làm gì để tìm kiếm kéo theo
thời gian thực nghĩa kết nối thẳng lên
đây B Để mình tìm tất cả sản phẩm phù
hợp trong ngoại
anh ở tôi lỡ đăng xuất rồi Tôi làm
nghiệp lại nha
à à
Ý anh là sự bây giờ thêm vào giỏ hàng
lần này tôi sẽ dùng GV thì mình sẽ hình
dung hơn ờ
Em in decan nó sẽ chứa cái phốp pháp này
của đắp như thế này
thường là ra ship Nếu phải để cuối chạy
lỗi nên là
tôi vẫn sẽ khai báo ở trong cái file
crack này cái dự Gia Huy ở cuối được
ngoại
sẽ bảo đây
ở
đây một đoạn Script
Vì sao đó đi three Play
ừ rồi vậy đi
rồi đây mình sẽ là mở gì kể bên cô đắp
này xem lại nhé Nó thể A để nghĩ đến cái
này đúng ạ Thế bây giờ mình thay vì nó
thể hiểu để đến thật sự bây giờ mình
cũng có một cái nút rồi đây mình cường
Hãy để nó là cái nút mình bấm vào cái
nút đấy nó sẽ thêm sản phẩm vào giỏ hàng
thì mình sẽ thứ nhất là mình sẽ đổi nó
vô tên em
theo dõi hàng này
nếu mà mình phải hiểu là khi mình bấm
vào cái nút ở đây đúng ạ thì thêm sản
phẩm này ngoài thành sản phẩm này không
phải xem sản phẩm này thì thông qua ID
rồi sản phẩm nó ngoại thì mình sẽ có
khái niệm ở đây đó là nó lận khái niệm
là truyền dữ liệu vào trong mấy cái mấy
cái kiểu nhà mới cái nút hai mình cái
bút gì đó nó sẽ data này khi đôi GP là
sẽ có khái niệm này nó truyền vào thẻ đã
tạo là chuyện nữa ATP ra đấy thì sẽ có
data thật sự đặt tên nó đã ai đi em ạ
bằng bằng cái gì sẽ bằng cái đoạn này
ở đó
ừ ừ
Ừ để mà mình hiểu là khi bấm vào cái nút
này bản chất là cái nút đấy nó sẽ có cái
có chứa cái dữ liệu ID là cái là cái sản
phẩm mình đặt Đông ạ Đây cái lớn nhất
thứ hai là bởi vì giờ sử trên tràn các
bạn đã có quá nhiều nút có nút ở trên
này nữa giả sử về sau có mấy nút trên
này thì mình phải hiểu là khi mình bấm
vào cái nút thêm vào giỏ hàng thì nó mới
xử lý cái thêm giỏ hàng thôi chứ không
phải bấm nút trên này nó thêm vào giỏ
hàng thì mình sẽ cần bình thường hay làm
là mình sẽ cho nó thêm cái class ở đây
để hiểu là khi bấm vào cái loại loạn nút
có class là
mình sẽ có cái nút class là bức Tân cái
tắt thì sẽ bút tình ngay thêm vào giỏ ha
là escuchar đúng không autocard như thế
này
class mấy ông lên để nhanh nha Tôi nói
rồi anh Cái dưới
đấy Chồng chồng chuyên nghiệp phết nha
tiếng Anh cứ thứ tư đề thi
bây giờ bây giờ để bắt được cái sự kiện
khi nút này được bấm thì mình sẽ có là
a-class mình dùng dấu chấm nhớ sẽ em ạ
khi click là khi được bấm này nó như thế
này Xóa even đi không cân đấy như này là
sự là bây giờ mình cứ load rồi một cái
là
khi nuốt được bấm rồi lại Ạ thông báo
khi mà nút được Bấm các bạn cứ chạy thử
chưa Đã xem được không nha Bấm vào này
tại nút được Bấm rồi này bấm vào này nó
được bấm rồi ok đấy Tớ làm chị à cứ bất
kỳ cái nút là mà có cái class này thì
khi nó khi mà nó được click không ạ thì
nó sẽ chạy toàn bộ cốt ở trong này đó
Thì bây giờ mình cần lấy ID của cái sản
phẩm đấy Giống như mình vợ để thằng bé
bao tay đi này thì mình sẽ có là ID sản
phẩm mình sẽ đặt IP bằng đôla bất ngờ
cái này họ giết này em chưa gặp mày chỉ
nghe cái nút này ông ạ Không phải là cái
nút khác chính cái nút được bấm thôi và
mình sẽ lấy
data-id này Đây đây chính ở thấu kính
data data
ông bà bây giờ Bữa nay mình sẽ bà like
đi nên mình sẽ ghi trong này ai đi để
hiểu lấy ID về đấy Bây giờ mình lại thử
ở lớp đến phát nữa cho chắc đi Bạn đã
bấm sản phẩm
sau đó thì cậu về ID để các bạn với anh
Trung nhé em mình đã dậy một cái giữa
trận ngoạn
bấm vào này sản phẩm ideas này sẽ gọi đi
5 này đúng không đấy để phân biệt rõ ra
thằng này khác hàng ngày đi khác nhau
Không ạ
ạ bây giờ đương nhiên là không phải là
Hiển thị cho người dùng màu mè như thế
rồi cùng không thêm được vào giỏ hàng
thì bằng không đúng không Mình cần bấm
ra để thêm Tức là sao là kiểu gì mình
vẫn phải gọi đến cái file thêm vào giỏ
hàng này Autocad này ông ngoại Cái gì
mình vẫn phải gọi đến file này như là
bởi vì bên TP xử lý thì sẽ được chuyển
hướng sang thời trang đấy để Trang Đấy
chạy đồng ngoạn bản chất là các bạn xem
kĩ nhé là nó sẽ lấy cả ID từ đây Ghét
tất cả lấy trên thanh địa chỉ về để mà
thao tác các thứ thứ đúng ạ
Ừ thì mình cần ở đây là mình gần như cần
có cái from đẩy thông tin lên cái cái
file app afterward này đấy về để mà Cập
nhật cái giỏ hàng thì bây giờ mình sẽ
khái niệm ảo giác tôi làm chỉ mình sẽ
đẩy đẩy lên nhưng mà không tỏa lại trang
Quan trọng là không phải lại xa không
điều hướng sang đây nữa thì các bạn sẽ
có giác như thế này họ sẽ ra ngay nó thứ
nhất là các bạn điều Noel tức là file
tên là auto cad
chuẩn pp tiếp theo 2 chú tiểu phương
thức các bạn nó sẽ có ghét và boss
lareboss các bạn nếu rồi Giờ này mình
dùng Ghét vì ở bên này mình chuyển sang
là truyền ra ghét mình sẽ dùng ghét
nhưng mà thực ra về sau Các bạn
truyền hết thành post thì ổn hơn như
mình từng nói vì boss nó bảo mật hơn và
ghét chỉ phù hợp để lấy thông tin về
hoặc là tìm kiếm chứ không phải ạ
anh nói chung là có một vài cái thì các
bạn nên để tốt hơn rồi ghét cho an toàn
có kiểu dữ liệu là kiểu dữ liệu các bạn
sẽ chặn trả về để mà để làm gì thì mình
cứ tạ ẩn nó đi đã rồi tí mình sẽ giải
thích thế theo bata là cái là mình sẽ
truyền lên mình truyền lên Như mình bảo
mình sẽ truyền ID không ạ Mình sẽ chuyển
AD nè đây nếu các bạn Nếu các bạn chuyển
id thì các bạn phải ghi kiểu như hai đứa
rồi
Ừ để hiểu lại truyền biến ID lên tên nó
lai đi luôn nhớ cái được rồi Thi ở đây
sẽ có những khái niệm này
khi mà chạy thành công này khi mà chạy
thất bại này và khi là chạy Xong này
mình thường hay xoa cái khi chạy xong đi
mình sẽ chỉ quan tâm là khi chạy thành
công thì sẽ thất bại Thôi thì chạy thành
công thì sẽ làm gì khi trả thất bại sẽ
ăn gì nhà mình
bây giờ mình cứ chạy các bạn xem đã
à à
ở
nơi đầu tiên anh xem cửa hàng nữa nha A
giỏ hàng nếu thấy có Samsung của iPhone
13 đúng không
Bây giờ thì cái iPhone Sky ơi rồi đúng
không Bây giờ sự tự bấm vào đây thì cần
hiển thị lên cái này đúng không Nhưng
trước trước đây đã cho mình không xem ẩn
inspect này xong ngồi ẩn bên A Tab
Network này
Anh bình thường sẽ có cái ô này như ông
sẽ bấm vào bên fake acchelper.xll để bắt
được cái gói tin mà mình sẽ truyền sang
Mã rắn
Ừ vợ giao diện Ok
bây giờ rồi mình bấm vào này đó thì mới
ông thế là nó sẽ truyền vào tin này lên
nó sẽ có là
dự
báo sẽ chuyên ai đi lên là 8 được chưa ạ
là ai đi rồi sản phẩm này và nó sẽ trả
về kết quả freestone ở đây trở về cái
hiển thị ra đây bởi vì ở đây Tôi đang
hiển thị ra ra mày không có hiển thị ra
đâu nhưng mà nó trả về có thể không cần
trả về đây chỉ chả thử thành công hay
thất bại cũng được
thường là trả về thành công đúng không
Mày không thấy à nếu mà một khi nó có
trả lời gì đó thì nó sẽ có status là 200
đến nay tức là thành công nó sẽ chạy vào
cái xe nhà
ê sexy này bé ông thể ấn với cao show
mày ông sẽ thấy sao xít lại còn mỗi khi
ở tôi không trả lời cái gì cả như này
còn trường hợp như thế này bấm vào nữa
này
ở Hà Nội ở Syria
Ừ Ừ hình như là không trả lời gì nó cũng
sắp ít nhưng trừ khi ông trả về hẳn là
số không gì gì đó thì như là vẫn phô Vậy
thử nhé
anh vẫn sexy à
Ừ ừ ngờ rơi và cái trường hợp phone thì
bây giờ nhiều hôm đang là rơi trường có
phone khi mà ngày nó trả về ý sắp sinh
Ừ tôi không nhớ lắm
mình cái Hà rất này để thử nha theo
exceptional ạ
Khi bữa là 200 hay
ở
những trường hợp nào Cái hài nghĩa phone
được quên nó rồi đấy
Isaac này 4
à à
Anh đợi ở thị xã à Em lo lắm không dùng
Hải quen hơn
Ừ ông ai còn chọi Chị dùng xấu xí Tôi
không dùng phone rồi
số taxi ở Bắt trường hợp dữ liệu trả về
nó có chữ alo hay không cũng được
Ừ cái phone này thường là hình như mình
nhớ không lầm ở Phone này nó là lỗi Liên
quan được là không tìm thấy file này thì
xe là phone ạ Không tìm thấy file đường
dẫn này nó sẽ là Phone này Thế mình nhớ
đúng này
mà còn thêm một vài cái nữa cơ nhưng
mình không nhớ lắm à
i
a do nước ngoài phải để ở đây nó luôn
thông báo nó là sao tốt là 200 thành
công đáng thể dùng Abbott cũng được mà
không ngại ôm boss đây sẽ là gì nhỉ đổi
nói chưa đổi cái như bạn kia đang bảo là
đổi header sao tất thành 40 42 thể thành
có gì đó nữa thì nó mới sai con ở đây
Các bạn thấy vui rồi giờ sự đây cốt lỗi
nữa nó vẫn sẽ bảo luôn bảo thành công
nên là nên lại ấy thường là mình sẽ làm
như thế này thì sẽ yêu cơ chế giống như
vừa rồi mình tại chỗ không người cho một
chai tức là là sửa khi thành công hết
mình sẽ
một ở đây và đây mình sẽ kiểm tra data
trả về nếu nó mang một thì mình sẽ ý
thành công còn nếu nó bọn không thì sẽ
in ra thất bại trận trước nhờ mày thật
ra các bạn cũng chả các bạn chị chơi ở
trai cát để kiểm tra xem tất cả thằng
này có đúng hay không
ở đài kiện nha à
em có gửi ví dụ cho một cái
à à
em dạy mấy hôm qua một tí với trai cát
luôn Mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ lại cho một
nha trở lại đây sẽ cho không nghe trở
lại
vào đây mình sẽ ra
Xóa đi này ít data bằng bằng
thì mình sẽ ra kiểu
cho Air Blade Thành công đi à
hệ thống kia lại hỏi nguồn học bằng
tiếng Việt là dở
thất bại đi
à à
Em bấm vào này Thành công nấu ạ thành
công đưa như nổi vì cố tình chạy được
mình sẽ cho một đấy Đúng bây giờ sự là
đây mình đội loạn hết cả lên như này à
Em bảo nó này thất bại đó Bởi vì trong
trường hợp này thì mình
Ừ mình vẫn trả về muộn à đi rồi nghỉ để
trả lời không nghỉ à
Ừ cái này nhựa lỗi của Pháp chứ không
phải
Samsung nữa sao
Đợi mình tí nhé bảo này các bạn đúng rồi
à à
ra mắt sự kiện
thì không ngờ cái bát sự kiện này lắm
Tại sao nó vẫn là một nhà ở
em thấy điêu điêu ạ
em không nhưng mà ý mình ở không không
nên học tiếng Việt Bạn em quen dần việc
lên hẳn đọc tiếng Anh của nó trang chủ
nói
ờ ờ cái chai Cát này thì ta là áp dụng
nhiều khi mà đến đón hay các bạn sẽ được
học là các bạn sẽ dùng cái này rất nhiều
và bác sự kiện là nó trả về thành công
ấy thất bại hơn còn ở đây mình nghĩ à
Nãy giờ có vẻ bắt vẫn không bắt được cái
cái này người yêu ơi
ở đây để tra thử nhé PB này chai các
ăn defined
ở trẻ sơ sinh
em yêu reset
à à
trò
chơi tự nông dân này
à À đúng rồi Thôi bồ mình quên đấy Cái
session exception thì bắt trường hợp
exceptional cần thôi bồ nó sẽ có cả nó
sẽ có cả lỗi thì cú phát và lỗi nhiều
cái hơn nữa lỗi lô gic hơn
hội trại lần này được này sang được bấm
và lại thất bại này
anh vẫn hết à
xe máy bị lỗi này điêu nhỉ
à à
Cho tôi xem nhé Đợi chị xem lại nữa
à à à à
ip7
trẻ sơ sinh
a nhớ dùng thôi bồ thì được rồi nhỉ
à à
em à cho riêng trường hợp trường hợp and
I find này chắc phải dùng eset rồi thâu
sắp sẵn rồi Đây là phải chơi còn ai thôi
đó là
một và cái này tồn tại này à
Ê kíp
MT là nếu không tồn tại cái thằng đôla
get là ai đi thì mình sẽ
sâu exception như thế này là
anh không tồn tại
Ờ ờ ai đi anh ạ Không cần cái kiểu ngay
sau đó gì đây mình sẽ rô đúng cái đôla e
à à
ở đây này thế chả được
Em bấm vào đây
Em Thành Công ạ Á đù nó xem cho dù đúng
bây giờ mình thử đổi nó thành kiểu như
thế này thì cho nó sự sau nhé bấm vào
này thất bại này đó không Tôi tải đi đó
đùa đấy được đấy
thì các bạn Thể muốn lấy cụ thể hơn Hình
như có ghét Miss it ngay được thì phải
nhớ lắm hả mà này lại không còn tại đi
Sau đó thì các bạn sẽ cần in cái lỗ đầy
ra được đây inter data tất cả cái lỗi
thừa mình sẽ đặt tên là nó một data2
restore mà thích quay trở về
nhà này
nếu mà resort là một chất là thành công
còn không thì mình sẽ hiểu là mình đã in
a Cái lỗi Tại nó sẽ như này bà 30 tồn
tại ai đi thôi chị ạ
xe tải phải chơi trường hợp là so với
sắp sinh chưa có vẻ là nó không bắt được
cài any file crack ở đây lại còn cho
trường hợp các bạn trả về nó là 12 Chu
gì gì đó thì sẽ hiểu là thành công rồi
đó ngoại thêm sản phẩm thành công Đấy
rồi là các bạn thấy mình áp dụng
vụ áp dụng
kết hợp với Iraq để mà thêm sản phẩm và
giỏ hàng khá nhanh không cần lại tả lại
cha nó không ạ ạ
anh ta minh thư cứ tải lại trang rồi
chạy một lần nữa gọi lại xem nhé Thành
công đóng ạ sau đó sang bên này ra sản
phẩm vừa nãy có thêm vài sản phẩm bị lỗi
thành nào được chuyển ngay
ạ Và bây giờ mình sẽ áp dụng cài gg Jack
để mà làm nốt cái bên này cái bên này
khó lại Bởi vì bên này còn rất nhiều nút
mình sẽ tối ưu việc à Không phải cứ bấm
vào trang này nó lại nhảy sang trang
khác Xong rồi nó lạnh điều hướng lại
quay lại chán này như thế này chỉ để
thay đổi một cái này là thứ nhất mình có
thể cộng cái cộng trừ cái dẫn nhanh Xóa
sản phẩm vị rất nhanh mà vẫn không còn
tại sao thì nó sẽ như thế nào
em nói mẹ uống hiểu trông ạ Chị sẽ như
thế nào ạ
à à
có bài review card ông ngoại ucash
anh vẫn là cái đoạn ra Swift để nó cuối
cùng không ạ ạ
những
ngày này cuối cùng này
rồi đi Này
bây giờ như tôi đã nói thật ra bây giờ
thứ nhất là phải đổi toàn bộ thẻ là mấy
cái nút không ạ
Đổi nó thành may cái nút
Ừ
thì mình sẽ
em lên trên này một tí này à
Hướng dẫn root - + hạn chế tí thôi sẽ
dậy mày ông về việc à đổi cái này thành
niên phút để người dùng nhập vào cũng
được cứ mỗi lần này dùng nhật thì tổng
tiền đó Tự động thay đổi đấy nhưng mà
như thế thì khi em nhập xong thì một là
nó núp cập nhật hay ạ nhập xong
Cho hỏi có thể nhập xong rồi bác sự kiện
là người dùng chỉ cần click ra ngoài vào
nhà là số lượng nó sẽ tự động cập nhật
trong giỏ hàng cũng được ở rất nhiều
cách để đầu tiên thì áp dụng cái Iraq
vừa rồi là khi mình bấm vào nút
Em
bấm vào nút này thì sẽ là thay đổi thay
đổi cái số lượng hẹn ước Cộng trước nha
nó cộng sẽ dễ hơn
mình sẽ đây cộng này
mình đây sẽ là class như mẹ tôi nói bất
tin
update
quan tivi
Ừ đúng rồi đa số dùng cộng với - chứ
không cho người dùng nhập số lượng
Ừ nhưng mà hôm trước có ông cứ đòi cái
đấy tôi chiều hết mọi người dễ dãi ờ
em làm gì này mình chuyển id vào
Ừ ok ba các bạn để ý kĩ à Và đây là con
truyền lên kéo trai tớ là kiểu kiểu nó
là cộng hay trừ cái gì đó thì mình sẽ có
data2 ở đây cũng được bằng mình sẽ có
thể bằng luôn đấy là in Grid tất là ta
ngày đó ông ạ Xóa luôn nó này đi đó
anh nghe này
Anh trông đẹp hơn cái này ngon mình cần
bấm ở đây thì sẽ ra cập nhật số lượng
nhiệt đúng nhé ngoài cập nhật kiểu vui
không thì mình sẽ cần làm là gì mình sẽ
ý là khi cả núi lại được bấm rồi ông ạ
kể update này được Bấm
class chấm click
anh là nhà này à
Ừ
Thì khi nó này được Bấm thì có những cái
gì xảy ra nhất là mình cần lấy cái ID
của các sản phẩm và cái kiểu dự kiểu
kiểu của nó nữa mình sẽ là led ID bằng
đôla rít
chấm
data-id này à
a tiếp theo hai triệu nó này sau đó mình
sẽ bỏ giác mình sẽ gọi đến
file file này
ý nghĩa là các bạn thấy ở đây rõ ràng là
mình không sửa cốt PT file những cái
file để gần như vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên mà
mình chỉ cần sửa lấy giao diện thôi để
nó không tải lại trang và thật ra chắc
là cũng sửa file này một tí là nó không
cần phải hết đồng ai nữa là xong cùng nó
lại để cho lại kiểu giống như mình vừa
phải cho một thế Cho không Nó để thông
báo thành công hay thất bại đúng không ạ
Cái này như mình nói về sau lên đội mới
thấy ghét
có kết quả Trở Về đây thông bạn ạ Kết
quả trả về chính là kết quả trả về từ
đây này vừa rồi Vừa nãy Các bạn thấy là
mình trả về hận kiểu chữ một và thông
báo thông báo lỗi hoặc là số số một họ
không ạ Tức là kiểu trở về của nó để
photo Tức là nó là HTML như thế này
thì các bạn hoàn toàn hệ trả về nhiều
kiểu hơn nhưng mà mình chưa dậy các bạn
điều này thì vẫn cứ xóa đi được đấy các
bạn cần truyền đây là ai đi và thay đúng
không ạ Các bạn chuyên đến hai cái này à
đó là sự luôn Đúng đấy Thực ra là mình
cứ bắt trường Đúng chưa Đã về mình cũng
có kiểm tra trường hợp sau này đấy đâu
ừ ừ
Ừ thì ở đây mình
vì Nếu giả sử đúng đúng thì mình sẽ làm
gì thế mà chậm đúng ở đây mình sẽ làm gì
đúng ở đây mình sẽ ok
à mình mình cất ạ Mình cứ tạm Bể đấy đã
Plus ạ
đã thành công trước bạn nhé
à à
anh bấm này Thành công này các bạn thấy
số nó vẫn thế nhưng bản chất là khi tải
lại trang khi tải lại trang này
Ừ đấy thì số lượng thay đổi rồi thế Thực
ra nó không ổn lắm Tại sao không ổn bởi
vì à Không phải mình bấm này thì đúng là
nó không trả lại cho mình đấy nhưng mà
mình vẫn phải tại chan thì mới thay đổi
số lượng ra thấy không nên không ạ nghĩa
khi là thành công ấy thì các bạn cần cập
nhật số lượng mà có cực các bạn cầm tổng
tiền này cần cập nhật tổng hóa đơn này
Đấy do mình bảo là toàn bộ những cái
tổng tiền hay là tổng hóa đơn này các
bạn nên tính nó bằng ra Swift Sau đó thì
mình sẽ
rồi Mỗi khi thay đổi một cái đây thì
toàn bộ những này được tính lại hoặc ra
Switch đấy
Ừ thì ở đây đoạn này mình sẽ thử làm
điều đấy cho bạn xem nhé á anh ở đây thứ
nhất là cái hiển thị ra cày
Ừ cái này và cái này non bộ mình sẽ có
khái niệm là như này
ờ ờ
à à
nhà mình có thường thường mình làm đấy
mình sẽ để thằng ngày Anh vào trong một
hẹn ở thẻ span a
chị
sẽ có la classe là à span
file chở nạn
này tiếp theo thằng ngày sẽ để nói cho
Star
Xem tiếp
ở
lại còn đi không ạ
Anh
và thằng này sẽ là span đây là class là
spam xăm lạ là tôi tổ tiên hay lúc đầu
mình cứ để nó chồng đi rồi mình sẽ làm
gì mình sẽ dùng ra Swiff của mình để cập
nhật cái
ra tổng tiền này dựa theo về đấy à
Lê Hoàng là lúc đầu các bạn có tính
trước cũng được không sao đầu hay dự cốt
củ đi nhỉ Mình cứ tình trước đi sau đó
đi dùng ra Speed về cập nhật lại sau
cũng được mà rất nhiều cách một loại các
bạn tính toán hết bằng tfp Sau đó thì ra
Suite mà tình lại hay các bạn tính toán
hết vào da skip sau đó đi có thay đổi
thì ra sức quy định tính lại
cho các bạn một cách nào dùng hết mà gia
quýt nhé quen dần việc chúng ra clip nhé
Ừ dạo này pp tính thì nó sẽ nhanh hơn đỡ
mất công thêm một đoạn mình làm ra Speed
thôi mình cơ
đấy Mình thì hiện Đinh Thị à
ở Facebook cũ rồi đâu vậy
thời xa xưa cái lại để yêu à
xe tải Tôi đặt tên là cái gì nhỉ
ở xa mà
Ừ
để cho đi đó là x tại quán tivi em nhắn
với
đội ích tại Prime
không Đây đây là
xăm này
ừ ừ
khi cài đặt đầy tô tô đi
ô tô tô tô
ở đầu tiên là Toto cộng bằng xăm này và
echo xăm này à
à mà vẫn thấy nóng bọn nó vẫn thế nhưng
bây giờ
cứ mỗi lần mình cập nhật Cái này xong
mình Cập nhật cái số lượng ở dòng nào
thì cần tổng tiền ở dòng đấy thay đổi
chứ không phải dòng dưới thay đổi để ghế
nhất không ạ thì mình sẽ làm là gì mình
sẽ cần ạ
cho
mình mình sẽ cần ở đây là mình thay đổi
cái số này trước đã cái gì Mỹ phải là
được số này cho đã thì mình sẽ ra à
Ờ Ờ
mình có khái niệm rất là hai này không
biết các bạn chơi cho cách nào khi cái
nút này được bấm ông có thể chơi cho trò
là gọi đến cái thằng
ở TD tra
rồi ông ngoại gọi đến thằng con fan con
của thằng bêđê đấy giống Cập nhật cái
giá trị số cho nó
anh hoặc là trận chiến ở trước tôi chơi
là tôi gọi đến thẳng t rồi tra để mình
còn cập nhật luôn cả cái ban tổng tiền
nó nữa đấy thì tôi sẽ làm theo cách gọi
đến tiêu rồi cha nghĩa là cái dòng cái
nút này được bổ đúng không Tôi sẽ gọi
anh cả để lòng này Được rồi tôi sẽ gọi
đầu tiên à Gọi số lượng cập nhật số
lượng này và gọi đến tổng tiền để cập
nhật thông tin này à
Ừ thì thì bây giờ tôi sẽ làm là người
sao
đề thi đầu tiên là
cái tôi vẫn phải lấy lại nút này nhưng
mà trong trường hợp này tôi mà khai báo
dùng Đôla đtđ ở trong này
tôi khai bà doris cho mày nhá
thì doris này nó lại của các fan chân
này là của hoa giáp khác với cái thằng
cái nút này nên là tôi thường ai sẽ bảo
cái nút này
ở đây đã
như này
Ừ ông có thể khai báo lại đây là một
tuần này qua tuần này ở đây sẽ ra và bây
giờ mình sẽ gọi anh Hoàng cha thằng tây
rồi
sẽ là les
parents
tr I
à à
Ê
bà bước tuần này gọi đến thằng cha
ở đây sẽ có cái khái niệm và parent vặt
Talent thêm chữ s
capella Night Cho nó tất cả gọi đến
thằng cha đầu tiên của nó là cái này cho
đầu tiên của mỗi tuần này nó sẽ tới D
còn kịp Holland thêm chữ s là ông hoàn
toàn thể truyền được nó
a parent thêm cho AE này thì không thể
gọi xấu hơn ông thể gọi đến thằng cha
nào đón nữa miễn ở ông khai báo giấy tờ
ông này nó tới rồi đó ngay à
anh có tiếp theo
gọi đến Hằng à
anh không cần tìm đến cái thằng
I span quantity này special Price đã sử
tôi có Read
file bằng
anh tệ Thái lên tay rồi họ đến
Ừ ông thấy ghi rõ thẻ span được còn vì
tôi chưa class rồi nên tôi gọi được Kiểu
như ai
span file này nó sẽ gọi đến Peru của nó
lấy dữ liệu nó đây đó tiếp theo là quan
tivi thế
à
Sao Bây giờ mình chỉ mình có tổng không
ạ Mình sẽ có led săn bằng Pride + còn BT
hả nhầm nhân con đi
Sau đó thì mình sẽ gọi đến thẳng span
em xăm này này
3.3 lu rồi mình chuyển xăm ở trong này
nó sóng thế giới sự với ông xem nhé
thứ hai đúng không Anh lên à quên quên
phải đổi số này nữa không đổi số này nó
ngân lên vẫn thế đợi thì tôi phải đổi số
ai nữa đó là cái này nó phải tăng lên
một thì đây mình sẽ là
khi dùng vs thì người dùng thấy được có
xử lý của mình thì sao thương ai quan
trọng hiếu cái này cái này dùng cái này
không mầm không cần bảo mật gì cả cái
này
đúng là nhiều người vẫn bị ngại vụ là
người khác xem cố tình mình để Cốc Cốc
hai à là kiểu biết được mình xử lý nha
để mà đôi khi lách kẹo bảo mật đấy nhưng
mà cái này thì đã không có gì bảo mật cả
thôi kệ những nhiều người về sau ngại vụ
người khác có cốt mình thì nó sẽ có khái
niệm là mã hóa cốt theo kiểu là
con feel code confuse
ra Swift à
chứ không phải gọi Coffee xin tôi chẳng
nhớ cái đấy lắm Nó có cái thư viện để mà
để mà mạnh code Swift vào sẽ được tương
đối mã hóa kiểu nó sẽ đổi hết Cái cái
hàm hay là tên biến thành ABC để mà kiểu
thằng khác khó lọc cốt của ông hơn thôi
à Đấy lại off phu cái gì đó kìa nó ra
không hẳn đã cần lắm
Vì
sao không nhớ đâu để tao còn dùng đâu
Tôi chỉ biết qua rồi mà
đầu tiên là cái số lượng này nó phải
tăng đã thì mình nhân lên nó mới gửi
thay đổi không ạ số lượng vẫn thế thì
bằng không không ạ thì đây mình sẽ cho
- + + ở đây được không nhỉ
sự thành công mà thành công thì mình sẽ
quantity này cộng cộng này sau đó thì à
mình phải
anh như thế Thằng này nó lại phải lặp
lại một lần nữa thì mình cho nó vào con
đi nhé
Anh sẽ được
Em bấm vào này
vì nó không được
Ừ anh em nãy giờ mình đang dùng ta mình
quen cái này phải đổi thành tách nhá vì
giá trị
tách này đây lấy mình đang một lấy số
rồi trong chính cái này mà xe tải
Em bấm vào này sản phẩm này
vi phạm Thị Tâm chưa
Ai biểu tôi tả lại cho em thì mới Ông
thấy giống hệt nhau này
vợ chồng không thiếu duy nhất thay đổi
đây mấy ông thấy khó chịu và cái tổng
tiền ở dưới này đúng không Thì mình cần
làm gì khi mình cần tính tổng lại như
này đúng ạ khi mình cần tính tổng lại
nha Thì cái tổng tiền tổng hóa đơn đấy
Nó phải lấy lại tổng của tất cả cái này
khi đó ngoại
anh hoặc là mấy ông có thể chứa trò là
cộng - nào không biết nhau tôi thường
hay thấy ạ Lấy tổng tổng của tất cả cái
này nó nhanh mình sẽ có khái niệm ở đây
là mình mình tính lại Tàu
như thế này mình sẽ có là ờ
I span sao mẹ ngon mình cần cái tổng của
toàn bộ cái săm đấy
cô hồn cốt Mình chưa đủ chuyên nghiệp
nỗi là khác đi Công Quốc mình về đâu
không đứng có lạc quan anh thế nữa
tôi còn không sợ chứ Đấy người không
Mình cần lấy tổng của tất cả những cái
cái thẻ spa này thì không rõ mấy ông
chơi cách như nào Tôi thường ai chạy
vòng lặp lại đây xong rồi ạ
Đấy tổng của nó thôi
xe máy cách dễ nhất thôi
3 cách đỡ khó hiểu nhất
à à Hôm nay tôi sẽ lấy tổng của nó
khi hòa Hình như có hàng thì phải không
nhớ có hàm không sẽ led đây xăm alesto
mà không đi sau đây là
anh Xóa Ai địch được tôi đang rảnh không
Đồ giết hết tô tồ cậu bằng đôla rít chấm
Tech đó để lấy tổng chứ
Ừ
cái này tính lại tổng của tất cả chứ
không phải lấy mỗi tổng ở trên này thì
cậu mà nó nhé ạ
khi chạy thử lạnh xe mày
ở đây
U21 lấy tổng đài quên quên quên lấy tổng
ra xuống phải in vào nỡ ngọn tốt ồ này
đợi tôi tí Nếu mà như này thì chạy Xong
phối
ê ê
anh chạy phối Cường này không được
anh chạy phối kiểu này xong tháng ngày
thăng
để tôi nói Tại sao không được Nếu sẽ
nghĩ là chạy sang vòng lạ rồi mình sẽ in
cái tổng vào là được đúng không ạ để đưa
cho anh xem nhé Ở đây tôi sẽ đổi cái này
Total vẫn đúng như tôi sẽ để thứ hai
cháu phải spam này
em hãy nói duy nhất thì tôi để nó ai đi
Fan Total này à
à à
I
spent oto.bi Là Totoro gì
thì ở sẽ in r tổng đúng không
khi bấm máy
ở cổng chữ ạ thế để biến Anh chữ luôn
ê
kê tổng đề là Hiểu + chữ đấy sẽ là mình
sẽ pop up Flash đi v-app kiểu nó hình số
anh xem lại nhé à
Ừ Ừ mai trong trường hợp này nó nhanh
cái loại vô x là à Cái ích này nhanh lên
hàng ra cái tô Tô này vẫn được tính luôn
nhưng mà ra Speed nó là ngôn ngữ sự bất
đồng bộ đôi khi cái này chưa kịp tính
xong thì cái tô Tô nó đã chạy xuống dưới
này rồi và Tô Tô Tại nó chưa được tính
xong nên nó sẽ in ra Kết quả nó sẽ có
thể sai nên là tôi không hoàn ở khuyên
mấy ông chơi cho nó có ích ax như thế
này xong rồi tô tô ngay mà đôi khi là
cần cái này chạy nó xong đã xử lý bất
đồng bộ hóa ra quyết Hồi đấy rồi đau đầu
quá chẳng may đoạn này thì có vẻ không
lỗi lên tôi sẽ không giải thích thêm gì
cả nếu sự Mori chữa Nếu người ông có lỗi
gì đó đều ạ ạ
Ừ không thì thường à
thường mà Mấy ông có thể chạy đi chạy
lại cái đoạn này ngay trong mạng được
Kiểu gì nó chẳng hiển thị thằng cuối khi
mà nó chạy đến cuối Vẫn thế thôi
có một cách
anh không Bởi vì mấy ông nếu mà ông làm
việc ra sao biết rồi mày không sẽ biết
nó bất đồng bộ Tức là cái này vòng là
mày chơi chạy xong thằng dưới này cũng
thể được gọi luôn và cái tô tồ này chắc
chắn là nó trở thành xong rồi nó sẽ chỉ
sai đấy xong là làm việc biết rồi biết
hết mà
à à
anh còn không thì ông sẽ phải là đấy
tổng tối tối nghĩa có hàm kiểu gì chả có
hành
thảm tổng của toàn bộ tất cả cái này
ngoạn hàm xăm đây xăm à à
a lady
à à
em chụp review của máy một cách
vợ
chồng đi đi cũng được
ở những cái này là mà cái này áp dụng
cho mà thằng kia nó cũng màn thì vậy
từ từ mày không thể copy cách này nhé
Tôi đang dạy mày ông kiểu kia tôi đang
hạn chế giới thiệu cho ông thêm nhiều
hành nữa mấy ông hôm nay ở đổ loạn thôi
từ hôm sau này vẫn chạy được mà lỗi để
lỗi của mấy ông về tính sau Ok
ừ ừ
ạ Bây giờ thì
Ừ tao vẫn sao rất nhiều phết Bây giờ thì
mình đổi nói anh trừ cái đoạn trừ nó khó
rất nhiều bởi vì à - Chỉ mì ông sẽ nghĩ
ở Ok cập nhật ở đây vài cái thay đổi
tổng tiền đó xong nhưng mà nếu mà - nó
bằng 0 thì mình cần xóa nó hẳn luôn đi
chứ không hiển thị nữa không chuyện ở
trở thành âm nó ngoạn thì thì nó sẽ phức
tạp không đồng ý
ở đầu tiên ở đây nha đầu tiên đấy đã bảo
là
mình sẽ cần phải sợ những cái gì đây
Ừ chị sẽ đưa nhiệt độ nút này không ạ
có lẽ đã chứ
thường là này thế thôi đội đây thì nó
thay vì
Em in Grid ecclesia thường 2011 cho nó
dễ hình dung hơn bên này tội Thế hai nó
là một thì sẽ hiệu tăng còn
U20 là sẽ hiểu tăng - này thêm một nó sẽ
hiểu tăng cái gì đó tương lai làm Thiệu
đấy
đây à
anh than
ừ ừ
ở những cái Thơ cần sửa lại nha
cách tải gif
hay bằng bằng không
à à
ở
hạng sao
chỉ bằng một nó dễ hơn bằng bằng không ở
đây tôi tôi đang sợ việc là
thằng không mày nó bị ếch kiểu hình
chuỗi
Ừ không thì ông phải ép kiểu đây nó là
Số này là số gì đó thì thay lên nó mới
đúng để xem nha không
Ừ thôi tội Ép kiểu hẳn đây đi pass email
ép nó thành số này
Ý em nói anh số bằng bằng không bằng một
thì cậu con em thì còn đi tiểu trừ này
từ từ này
Ừ nó ở đây trông có vẻ vẫn đúng ở dưới
rồi thử nhé
à à
Thế trưa nay
chứ không phải nó thay đổi rồi đó ông ạ
nhưng nếu có trở về mức 0 thì sao không
ạ Con trọng - về mức 0 thì mình cần xóa
luôn cả cái ra ngoài đi nó ngoạn xóa ra
ngoài đi rồi mình phải tính lại có thứ
thì đây mình nếu mà trong trường hợp ít
bằng không thì ạ thì mình sẽ
em không cần phải cập nhật mấy cái này
nữa mà mình cần Xóa hẳn ra ngoài đi thì
sẽ khái niệm lại
Holland chậm sai rồi vì mù sẽ đang ngắm
ta sẽ xóa hẳn luôn cả dòng đời đi nhưng
mà mình sẽ
Ê kíp
I
eat beef onette
bằng không
Anh
nghe rồi chắc đi
tao lần
A
thorough chuẩn bị mu rất thích hả mày
Xóa luôn cả giọng nói đi
còn không thì sao thì mình làm Cập nhật
cái đống này không ạ nhưng mình vẫn phải
tính lại Tàu thì vợ phải tới mẹ tao xóa
đi tình yêu tao Ok chạy thử nhé
để trả thù vợ hay đi
em có sĩ lâu ta lại cha nó
haircare kiểu đ** mà đó sau đó khi nốt
cái cuối này thì đương nhiên mất tích
lại tương tự thế lợi ích này nọ chị đơn
giản lại họ đến thằng cha của tới đâu
đấy Xong rồi Xóa xóa xóa đi đúng ạ Đây
mình sẽ để nút Tân là
x không ạ Mình sẽ có class cho nó là bức
Tân
Delete đ
Âm nhạc được đi lấy ở đâu
đấy nhiên phải chiều nay đi nó data-id
bằng chỗ lại đi
xóa ra ngoài đi là đi phỏng các à à
ở đây để tôi copy ạ ạ
Ừ ok ok Smart Tôi biết rồi đấy
à à Tân An
I Delete nè
Khi mà nó được click thì mình sẽ làm ở
đây là gì
em copy cái đoạn này đã
ở
đầu tiên thì nút này lấy lại được này ai
đi lấy đấy Thái bỏ đi này không truyền
hoa này mình sẽ đổi nó là delete
ở phòng khác đúng ạ
I Delete phòng khám này máy thép này
toàn bộ về nội dung này à
ở ga bây giờ mình chỉ cần quan tâm việc
là khi ở thành công thì cái nút này sẽ
bị xóa đi là cái nút này chấm với MU sẽ
bị xóa nó xong A
Gọi ấy thằng cha tôi đồ rồi xóa đi khá
cái dòng đấy là nó bay thử nha
ở
tập 21 x lửa à
à
Dạ có trường hợp
em có giá bằng không hả
em không ra đâu để con tim à
à à
anh
bấm này đó nhau không cần tải sang gì cả
và tầm tiền đó sẽ được tính lại mày
không để ý kỹ thông tin nhé
à À quên cô quen tôi sẽ gọi hàng tổng
tiền thế là cái này vì cái này cũng được
sử dụng lại nên thường là tôi sẽ cố Nhầm
cái hàm sẽ có phương trình nhớ ai mà
ghét tôi em ạ
bởi vì yếu Độc lập mà độc lập Tôi sẽ gọi
hàm này
I get Oh ở đây này và đây này đó
cho tôi thêm sản phẩm mới nha là sự và
lại bên trang này thêm sản phẩm thêm vào
này Thành công này ta đã tra này có hai
cái tăng tăng tăng cao thứ lên Chậm tiền
tăng - gửi đi tổng tiền ra
để xóa một cái đi đó thông tin ra ok
chưa tà lại trang vẫn thế đó sẽ trải
nghiệm người dùng tốt hơn nhiều rồi đúng
không Đó đó là kết hợp Siri kết hợp uruk
để mà các bạn hoàn toàn làm được Kiểu nó
trang web gần như trong các động mình
bảo ấy năm chia nó kêu dạng theo thời
hiển thị 1 phát ăn ngay chứ không phải
load trang trải nghiệm người dùng khó
chịu dọn mạnh ông nó cùi bắp nữa khó
chịu hơn nhưng thôi ra cái này nó cũng
Ừ nó cũng sẽ nhược điểm các bạn thấy
cũng phải sửa khá nhiều cốt ông ạ Có các
bạn sẽ dài hơn so với hồi mình chỉ có p
thuần cái cái cái này nói chung rồi ông
nào mà kiểu Cảm thấy hứng thú và ông ấy
làm xong tương đối xong kia rồi mấy ông
mệt qua đây
anh hả
vì số lượng bằng không ạ sử dụng bằng
không Đây Rồi thì em làm sao
em xem có cách nào để chặn người dùng
dùng lá sắc đến server tùy ý không ạ thì
cái này chính là bên mình từng nói là
các bạn nên có thêm cái đoạn to Ken để
mà ở đây mà phân biệt được à người dùng
tự truyền lên hay là do trong cái phone
nó chưa lên theo cái này khó ngăn được
Nhiều thằng muốn lấy thằng lớn nó không
ăn được việc giờ sáng tố không ạ Không
ăn được các bạn giả mạo cái phom để mà
điền thông tin 7 thông tin Lê
Có khó gì à thực ra là người dùng thể
vẫn có thể giả được giả được là như một
người thợ
ờ ờ
cái nói chung nhà bây giờ còn cái gì có
thể nói qua được nhóm nhạc
ở những cái buổi sau ở Tôi sẽ dậy xong
rồi này Ờ thay đổi số lượng dồi này
Xin chào tương đối thế thôi nhỉ Ừ Từ giờ
thì thôi cùng lắm là đặt hàng ở đây chứ
cũng không tải lại trang nữa nhưng mà
thôi ra dùng lá sắc các bạn vừa rồi biết
qua rồi Thời buổi sau nữa mình sẽ dậy
thêm với mấy cái này ờ
ở đây mình sẽ cho các bạn xem đầu tiên
thì nó qua vì kia Cốt
tất cả kia cốt thì có nhiều bạn chưa
biết bây giờ Swift phải chuyện có khái
niệm khi cốt
như này hơn là sửa các bạn vào trang này
các bạn ấn lên tôi thì nó sẽ ra 13 lắm
chị ạ Thực ra bất kỳ kết cái
phí mà các bạn gõ xuống - click chuột
cái ngày thôi thì nó đều có cái khái
niệm đã khi cốt tất cả là cái mã số của
cải cái nút mà các bạn bấm xuống mã số
bao nhiêu là sữa enter là 13 dầu cách cả
32 rồi xong rồi toàn bộ những cái Giả sử
mình đang gõ lại quý này nó 812 gì đó
với Vân Cái này để làm gì cái khi cốt
này hoàn toàn áp dụng tốt cho nhiều lúc
mà các bạn kịp còn bắt người dùng khi mà
bấm một cái nút gì đó nó sẽ yêu thì làm
cái gì thừa bấm enter nó sẽ kiểu nhảy
cái gì đó hoặc cả ấn phím x x kênh này
thì nó sẽ đẩy cái gì đó rằng ạ khi
mở control này hồi trước có trang web là
kiểu bấm mấy cái phím
trước trong Facebook mà cũng làm gì
không được như bỏ
ấn An một nhảy sang cái trang cho thằng
Ân ám hay nhảy sang trang
Xem lịch sử nhật ký hoạt động vân vân
lỗi rồi cái đèn tôi thích cái đấy Vãi
kiểu để mà Tab một cái gì nhanh An cộng
với phim cộng với một cây nữa nó sẽ nhảy
ra một cái gì đó nữa Rất là hay
a tiếp theo là
khi cài Tôi không nhớ lắm
Ừ hai cái này hay Cái nâng cao bên la
Wow thôi
khi cài hay phết tôi tôi để đây cho mấy
ông đọc thôi chứ thực ra là ờ nhất là
cái này bên mẹ mày có shop
Ừ hình như trong public có trong máy
queo thì tôi chưa thấy ở nhờ không có Nó
ghi cho Phương Trinh và thêm cái nữa là
cái này cái này là cách 2 vpower tốt hơn
tôi từng nói qua rồi Khá bị nghiện iy
như là có gì hay hay Từ hiểu chia sẻ
được với ông
Ừ cái này là cách ưu nhiều khối trước vợ
từng nói qua Hồi mà dậy mai con số
pasquale rồi Tôi từng nói qua là hồi mà
lấy ví dụ 3 bạn điểm cao nhất chẳng hạn
vừa đấy mình vẫn bị nhầm khi mình lúc
phải dùng top lúc phải dùng rau rapper
ấy thì à
thứ hai nó giải thích rõ ra tốt cho nó
hạn chế gì cho number hạn chế là gì rất
là tốt là sẵn chế hài nó dùng CT nữa xe
này tôi nghĩ chắc chắn nào cho trong máy
của em không có này CT à khai báo trước
một cái gì đó xong gọi ở dưới dùng hạnh
trình Cái đấy
đi theo dạng bằng kiểu ít như thế này
anh nói chung là đây 3 cách để mà kiểu
ghi code anker tốt hơn tôi đã nói mấy
cái này là để các bạn lưu lại này và các
bạn nếu mới về xong muốn tìm hiểu sâu
hơn về que thì mày cái rất tốt tôi được
gợi ý tội gì không đọc không ạ bởi vì đi
làm giờ sự tôi đang làm phu sắc ở công
ty nhưng mà các bạn mà biết thêm để cả
bên bác em xấu hơn để queo có thử thứ
thì sẽ chọn ạ thì nhà Lương đãi ngộ hai
à không lại lương mà nói chung là kiểu
các bạn có tầm quan trọng các bạn sẽ cao
hơn rất nhiều sau mấy ông chỉ biết cốt
đầy đủ tính năng thêm sử Thái cản ạ Có
ông ấy không biết làm thống kê câu không
biết là không biết tối như cô lạnh hay
và vân tối ưu cốt thì khi khó hơn mày
nói liên quan hệ toán cũng như là
về Ok này hay à
à hay là vị sau các bạn thật là cốt ông
nào chẳng cốt được bây giờ mấy ông cũng
có được rồi Nếu nhiều năm kinh nghiệm
thực ra cốc hơn mấy ông Tý
Ừ thì mình sẽ phải biết thêm vừng những
cái liên quan hệ em kia O2 toán gì nữa
Thôi không chưa được Toàn Tôi không nói
mấy ông được hoặc cả Lập trình hướng đối
tượng
ở cấp thứ thứ
Ừ cái này tôi nghĩa hay thôi cứ để đây
cho béo không thể tham khảo Sau bao giờ
mình sẽ nói nốt về cái đít trước khi
nghi ngờ không thử xem Mấy ông hiểu được
gì không nhé
I
[âm nhạc]
just keep this in Turn Around you of
Death and when to Use you to use a way
of my first not intended for fun and
fixes futakomori Browser Windows and
asking all
enemies speaking practice of Death is
the weather and cities and that instead
of the Battle of Viet the same way the
Battle of the winds now You Feel
surprised vest inside the person you see
that people the work on with paper from
inside their thoughts And now provides
get on with Sweet speculate estella for
inspiration English is the arya Stark ở
nước nào National trust in you in you
improve the value of Death is on the
performance and insight fasting and
speaker system for the person and
kestrel contact with the skilful hands
and the windows and Butter the window
For Fun with all of
us
Anyone you can understand that in the
yard get more out of the windows and
therefore when i first day of the doctor
in a third show as in the heart When is
Christmas to know when it's all you
think I know that low friction pager ups
and ask about you of us is Take to the
wheels on which utaite France
internationale Ê Trái tim and stays with
the windows and find all the Girls We're
always Yours trong Chrome engages in
every malfeasance
alo video vừa rồi ông nào mà hiểu được
hết nghỉ thì chắc chắn làm việc cho ra
xuống rất nhiều rồi Còn ông nào mới chưa
hiểu Thì đại khái video vừa rồi khiến
cho cái từ đít là rất là khó hiểu à Ừ
cái gì còn đô la gi Nó còn khó hiểu hơn
nữa git nó khác đưa giúp nhé
Ừ nhưng mà cái từ rít ở trong thẳng
Tuyết nó đại khái như thế nó rất là cặp
đôi khi mình không biết là cái j trong
trường hợp này nó gì mình phải luôn i
lại cái Zip để biết rồi xem nó là gì ạ
thường là như thế
bạn kia hỏi là mình đi làm 01 năm kinh
nghiệm thôi mà đã làm fullstack với vì
mình học ở chiến trường mình đã học ra
Switch và pp xong rồi học cả phím gốc
rồi
rồi mình áp dụng cái đấy thì mình làm
sản phẩm rồi đấy mình làm trang web quản
lý cho Trương Minh và cũng làm thêm khá
nhiều Tôi nói nên xông nhà mình kinh
kinh nghiệm thực tế cho mình ít nhưng mà
còn mà còn làm khá nhiều sản phẩm rồi
nên Thật ra là mình nói chung khả năng
tự học của mình tự mò của mình người khá
ổn đương nhiên là lúc mà mới đi làm này
mình xóa nhiều cái nhất là còn chưa bây
dùng ít này xong rồi à Mình còn phải học
thêm sớm quốc gia submit này nha Còn
rare về cơ bản thì mình tử vi khuẩn Air
Mình về mình tự học rất tự mò khá nhiều
chứ mình ngon hơn vai anh ở trong công
ty bởi vì vô vàn Gọi anh Công ty kia thì
biết TP thuần thôi Lara thì lại ít động
vào vì anh ấy biết nhiều ngôn ngữ Anh ấy
kiểu biết khá nhiều ngôn ngữ Java crack
xong rồi biết
stop1net lý gió thì ra là anh ấy không
chuyên hẳn Maria bằng mình
à à
khi mình học trường gì à Mình học nek AD
mình không khuya là mấy ông sẽ bây giờ
nên vào đấy à
Ê
con chó mình nhắn gọi đòn à bánh mình
cắt mình
các bạn có thắc mắc gì không nhỉ
ừ ừ
Ê mấy ông dạo này thắc mắc hơi ít hôm
nay xem lượng xe buýt Tôi thấy như người
ra buổi nó không hẳn là cơ bản nữa buổi
này cũng chưa sâu hơn tí ơi anh thôi cứ
nghĩ hôm nay 60 sai mình sẽ năm sáu ông
mới áp dụng cái này vào trong đồ án mới
ông thôi hoặc là mấy ông cùng lắm là xem
để cho biết thôi về sau
à Vì sao mà được nhắc lại thì cho xem
lại sau
à à
Thế
hả Chưa ra trường quan trọng béo hồi
trưa chiều mình đã làm cái cái đấy rồi
mà các bạn phải làm sớm à các bạn về
phải
thứ đang rảnh ăn gì không ạ rảnh ngoài
việc yêu nhau ra thì có thể
Đó
là những làm cái này nếu mà giờ sự đây
tôi cải mày tôi có đấy nhá này gọi tôi
chẳng chơi chơi thế hai bàn thua nhưng
mà ghê cơ bản thì cũng
1 cốc rất nhiều
cho tôi tôi khi hôm qua tôi ăn cạn ông
em đo xem thời gian cốt mấy ngày hôm nay
kiểu của chị cảm đâu mà cốt hiểu
Ừ tí tôi lại ngủ có tiếp này ngày nào
cũng hơn 10 tiếng thế
à
mà nó tôi coi nó đam mê vui chứ không có
làm được gì à Nhưng mà đương nhiên là
ngồi nghĩ nhiều đau đầu lúc mà đau đầu
như thế Chúng ta sẽ
ở tạm nghỉ giải lao dài tòa xong nó lại
ngồi có tiếc
gì hả ông kêu nợ môn À thì ra nợ mấy cái
môn mình không có trạm bị bỏ qua đi bởi
vì tôi không có tấm bằng cấp mà
anh nói chung ở thôi buổi hôm bữa hôm
nay
Khi bữa hôm nay chắc à tương đồ đến nay
có gì mình sẽ
khi dạy các bạn với toàn bộ những cái
này sau nhé những buổi sao
ở mỗi buổi mà dậy xong một cái này chắc
là hai tuần nữa rồi chẳng biết dậy Cái
gì nữa Em có thể gợi ý thêm Còn không
thì ra hai tuần nữa thì hai tuần nữa thì
đến Tết luôn cũng khá hợp lý sau Tết thì
chắc là tôi sẽ cho nó liên tục nhắc về
đoán xong rồi cho bảo vệ thở vân vân để
mà để mà bảo vệ thật Ôi không ạ ok
à à à à
ờ ờ
các anh chị khóa trên bảo làm đồ án dễ
chia tay nhiêu Ừ làm đồ ăn cùng với
nhiều chỗ làm dễ chia tay rồi ông ạ
the first time while time từng là cái để
mà đo thời gian nhé đó thời gian sẽ lưu
lại trong lại Exciter hoặc trả chậm
trong sách ở trong của mấy ông mà đo
thời gian mấy ông đã Cốt
ờ ờ đúng rồi mình dậy là một web hoàn
chỉnh từ đầu đến cuối
Ừ thôi có gì Các bạn có thắc mắc cứ bình
luận sau nhé mình chả bộ không ai tạm
nghỉ đấy thôi Thế bạn nhé à